okay let's make us
so thank you for coming along to this
talk and the one of the last talk
by now my name is Steven haunts and this
talk is on hacking humans and it's about
social engineering techniques and how to
protect against them so this is rough
agenda of what we're gonna look at in
this talk so we're gonna talk about what
social engineering is we'll look at some
famous cases we'll go through some
high-level social engineering techniques
and a framework for social engineering
and then we'll talk a bit about how you
can protect yourselves and your
organisations from social engineering
before we look at a few further
resources so how to put a disclaimer in
here so social engineering engineering
Germany leads to a legal activity
so obviously this talk isn't condoning
that the talk is ultimately about
protection and Prevention but we're
gonna look at some of the techniques
which help us protect because you don't
wanna be this guy ended up in prison for
doing something bad
so social engineering is a huge subject
so treat this talk as the art of the
impossible I mean you could literally
spend your lifetime learning all about
the cycle the psychology and all the
different tips and tricks that these are
tricksters use so this is kind of like
an introductory framework to how a lot
of this stuff's done well first of all
this starts off of a bit of a story so
we have a guy called kief who works in
technical support for a large company
and he's sitting there through the
middle of the night waiting for the
phone to ring but also waiting even more
for his next tea break so you can go
play pool with his friends so he gets a
call early in the morning from a what
sounds like a very panicked executive at
the company and the guys on the phone
his name's Tom he's out Keefe I'm in a
lot of I've got his presentation
has to do for the investors tomorrow
it's worth 100 million dollars if I
don't get this sorted we're gonna be in
trouble I've locked myself out of my
machine and I can't get back in and
password resets not working can you help
me so Keefe sis now thinking oh my god
is an executive at the company it sounds
quite severe it was okay yes I'll help
you there's lots of problems so he tries
to go through get the guide to go
through the automated and password reset
but the guy says it just doesn't work
and he's getting quite irate at this
point so look can you just reset the
password for me on your end
I haven't got time to mess about so
Keith decides okay I best do it so he
resets a password for this particular
user account that the guy wants resets
and tells him what the password is and
the guy is very thankful to a thank you
you've just saved my career because if I
don't get this presentation done then
I'll be in a lot of trouble so he puts
the phone down and keeps sitting there
very happy that he's done his good deed
for the day he's imagining himself
high-fiving what his friends down the
corridor you know he's literally saved
one of the executives in the company
meanwhile our executive team who's
really a hacker is logging in via those
credentials and stealing lots of files
so clearly this is a very simple example
sort of a quite a trite example but just
goes to show you the point about how
some of these tanks can happen within an
organization so let's look at what
social engineering is so here's a good
definition of it it's the act of
influencing someone to take an action
that may not be in their best interest
and we'll come back to this definition a
little bit later it's as three general
methodologies when it comes to social
engineering attacks that we see out
there so the first one is phishing which
is kind of one we're all familiar with
where we get those dodgy emails from
Nigerian princes and all those sorts of
people trying to get us to click on
links and give up details enough one
which is quite common is phishing which
is kind of a similar principle to
phishing but it's all done over the
telephone so has anyone had one of those
call centers phoned them ups claiming
that their Microsoft and their detected
a virus on your machine and you know for
$200 we can clear the virus for you so
that's that's a standard phishing attack
and the final one is impersonation so
you have people actually physically
trying to impersonate other people to
gain information which is the one we're
gonna be focusing on later in the course
at the talks I so I just wanted to go
through a few statistics these
statistics are taken off of a website
called social engineering dot org and I
think they're probably biased towards
the US but they kind of want to
illustrate a point so 90% of email is
spam so Gnaeus what my inbox looks like
and fishing represents about 77% of all
social based attack so fishing is you
know the biggest type of social
engineering scan that's out there and
it's one that affects most people and
clicking links accounted for 88% of all
reported fishing incidents so if we
learn if we look at fishing
say 2.4 million customers were targeted
for phone fraud in 2012 alone and 2.3
million customers are targeted phone
fraud just in the first half of 2013 so
this type of fraud is getting
exponentially more serious and the
average loss for a targeted business and
again this is slanted to the US was
around four to two and a half thousand
pounds or dollars rather per account so
impersonation so a few stats are gained
from social engineering to talk so
medical ID theft is on the rise due to
websites impersonating medical providers
which shows 1.8 million victims of this
in 2013 alone and it's a top and the top
place for ID theft is actually the
workplace where you work so if any
information is going to get stolen about
other people it's going to come from the
workplace an 80% of these FAFSA involves
disabling or bypassing controls so you
know these organizations may have very
good Network protection and firewalls
and perimeter protection but all it
requires is someone within that
organization to start by passing some of
these controls then you have an issue
and finally one on there is 88% of
reported stolen assets where personal
data so personal data is very valuable
it commands a premium price on the black
market especially if you've got medical
information included with that personal
data so if we look at some of the types
of social engineers that are out there
so you know you have you your typical
hackers your penetration testers are
people that are legally you know and
ethically trying to help organizations
protect themselves
I mean look your typical spies identity
thieves this grants would employees is a
very big one for bait effective in
organizations recruiters you know
they're very good at trying to
manipulate you into going for interviews
with jobs as part of their role as a
sales role
governments and also salespeople so
salespeople were there to try and
influence you to maybe buy something
which you don't really need to buy it
but they're gonna try and convince you
but can anyone think of another good
example of a social engineer your boss
has a good one but um pickup artists
yeah anymore
politicians yeah or my favorite one
children certainly my kids they can that
they can wrap around the little finger
so why do people do social engineering
and the reason is because it
consistently works it's very easy say
extracts information out of people if
you just know which buttons to press and
generally as I said before no matter how
much you've invested in network
protection and software and all that
people are still gonna be the biggest
vulnerability of any network especially
people within your organization and also
offers the path of least resistance so
you know you could spend a lot of effort
trying to brute force crack passwords
etc or you could spend some time
manipulating someone to try and reveal
secrets or passwords to you so some
common types of attacks so people
targeting customer service staff within
organizations this is typically done by
phone and they'll be trying to get email
addresses of people within the company
for example delivery staff is another
good one so people posing as a delivery
agent for say DHL or one of the other
couriers well they're to do is turn up
in a brown boiler suit with the package
under their arm and a rather convincing
McCain ID badge and the chances are they
going to be letting to your company lots
of our phone calls into the organization
targeting staff and I was targeted on
this one so I work for a large internet
banking the UK called egg and we had a
period of time where someone was going
around phoning different people in the
IT department trying to ask us different
questions to get effectively a logical
idea of what our server architecture was
so that I could I don't know what they
eventual goal was mean all of us were
quite savvy and we'd had some level of
training about this so we will reported
it so for that guy it didn't work he
wasn't just talking
person is actually called in about 12
people fairly regularly around the
company posing to be another member of
staff in the organization because
on-site in the office we were working at
we had about 3,000 people so it's very
difficult to know everyone and tech
support as we went through and a little
story at the beginning so tech support
is a very good way of targeting someone
people in tech support especially fo
very new in their career are very eager
to please and want to help so they don't
want to be seen as a barrier to helping
out someone else in the company okay so
we look at a few sort of famous cases
and considering were at a security
conference you people are probably gonna
recognize quite a few of these so the
first one is guy called kevin Mitnick
everyone heard of him okay so it's quite
a high-profile case so he was he spent
quite a lot of time in prison and he he
did various attacks like that computer
cooperation where he used to hack in and
steal software from their systems so he
spent 12 months in prison for that one
alone and he also used to do things when
he was younger like trying to hack the
LA bus system so he could get free rides
and the bus network so that's kind of
how we started off with sort of small
scams like that and then he sort of
increasingly got bigger and bigger and
bigger so he spent quite a lot of time
in prison he was charged with 14 counts
of fraud 8 cases of unauthorized entry
as well as a lot more charges but he's
now a reformed character so now he runs
a very successful security consultant
see where he goes in and teaches
organizations how to protect themselves
from people like him he's written some
really good books
I highly recommend reading these ones if
you're interviewing about this sort of
subject so the art of intrusion and the
art of deception of really good
textbooks and then you've got ghost in
the wire which is kind of more like his
biography it's a fascinating read you're
free interested in that so next one
which people have probably heard of is a
guy called Frank havoc gnarly so he was
a conman and confidence trickster in a
check for juh and it's claimed that
during his career he took on around 8
different personas or identities to
carry out his crimes including an
airline pilots
doctor and a lawyer so the fact that he
managed to trick his way into the cabin
of an airplane and pose as an airline
pilot is quite scary so the people
probably heard of him from this film
we've Leonardo DiCaprio and Tom Hanks
could catch me she can't has anyone seen
it so he's a Hollywood dramatization of
his story yes pretty good film and
there's a bit from the film there where
you've got Leonardo DiCaprio he's there
posing as an airline pilot and the next
example want to look at which people
probably heard of is Charles Ponzi who
popularized the Ponzi scheme and this
was a mail fraud scheme which used
international reply coupons which you
would buy outside the US and then sell
them for a profit inside the US but then
he realized to make more money he needed
to involve more people in the scheme so
he effectively formed what we know as
the pyramid scheme so as people join the
scheme the money flows down the pyramid
this is going quite well
until at the Boston newspaper started
getting suspicious about his activities
it's like looking into tax affairs and
then after that it will started
unraveling for him
okay so let's look at some social
engineering techniques so social
engineering can be broadly broken down
into four different areas in a framework
so after information gathering
pretexting elicitation and then
manipulation so information gathering is
as it sounds it's about doing a research
before you try and attack someone I'll
do a social engineering attack against
someone so you're trying to find out as
much information you can from as many
resources as you can to build up a
profile of that person and the company
that you're trying to target many
different ways of doing it so a common
waves dumpster-diving
where you're literally going through
people's trash either at home or their
offices because you'll be surprised how
much valuable information is actually
disposed of during the day at work so if
you have an old copy of a design
document or some software that you're
working on and a new version comes out
which you print out you might you know
throw the old version in the bin because
it's not useful to you anymore but to
anyone else trying to find information
out about your company that's really
valuable so another thing is why about
going through the bins so people can do
it at your home as well
if you leave you bin out say the front
of your house and they could be looking
for all sorts of things like you know if
you've got lots of alcohol bottles in
there then they'll probably know that
you like a drink so one of the ways I
can try and engage with you is by
getting you down the pub prescriptions
as well so if you're on particular
medication you might have thrown away
prescription details or medicine bottles
well that gets people a lot of
information about any particular
illnesses you might have which again can
be used to blackmail you or use as a way
of opening a conversation with you or
even things like if your are them into
vintage cars and you fry weight some old
magazines of vintage cars it kind of
gives people an interest or an idea of
what your interests are which can be
used as a way of starting or initiating
the conversation with you other
techniques but I'm sure you're all
familiar with is using social networking
so the amount of information that we all
post daily on social networks is quite
vast and there's lots of people who
still post quite a lot of public
information on Facebook and don't
necessarily lock it down
to their friends only and I've warned
few of my friends about this before who
are completely non-technical people but
you look at their Facebook accounts and
everything's being posted as private as
public Twitter again is very open
LinkedIn is very open so if you're
trying to find information out about
people's career histories we are trying
to link different people to different
companies and form some kind of
organizational charts then LinkedIn is
perfect for that these days things like
Instagram as well people seem to be very
willing to share lots of information on
Instagram so you can go through their
history and find out what they're like
as a person what their interests are
holidays have been on pictures of their
children you name it it's all going to
be on there and then you've got the good
old fashioned Google or Bing searches
always include being on there because
you'd get some people here that liked it
but just googling information on people
you'd be surprised how much information
you can find so malware as well is a
great way of doing information gathering
did anyone see Niles talk earlier but he
was talking about some of the ways that
you can use to inject malware onto
people's machines to take screenshots or
take log keys that they're pressing so
we have a lot of the tool kits that we
use today you know community like Kali
Linux all of those tools that we need to
do this lot of stuff is on there and
it's all for free and very fairly easy
to use so if you store a key logger on
someone's machine you know you can
capture their passwords as they're
typing them in if they've got sensitive
information on this screen you can take
routine screenshots of what's on their
screen so you can get fragments of
documents or bits of source code all
very good ways of gathering information
but obviously slightly more advanced and
just going through someone's rubbish or
googling on the internet looking over
someone's shoulder is a surprisingly
good way of guessing information so
before I left my last job I used to
commute about an hour and a half each
day on the train to get to work you'd be
surprised as you're getting into your
seat and you just peer over someone's
shoulder you can see exactly what
they're doing on their laptop or if
they're typing on their phone it's
really not that hard also as well
because as a people manager at my last
position if
ever writing their one-to-one notes or
appraisal race I had a massive window
which faced out into the office behind
me so I had to be very careful that when
I was doing anything sensitive like that
I have my laptop or screens moved away
from any windows where people could see
it's a very good way of gathering
information of course you could go to an
extreme and start using one of these and
these are parties do exist they called
privacy scarfs I've never seen anyone
actually use one but I did look it up
online you can buy them okay so that's
that's information gathering so that's
all about trying to find information out
about the people or the companies that
you're trying to target because that
information then leads in to the next
phase which is pretext in and pretext in
is the practice of presenting oneself as
someone else in order to obtain private
information so effectively it's about
acting you're taking on someone else's
persona to try and buy someone's trust
because you're trying to get information
out of them and it's more than just so
you know creating a simple life to get
information for someone you literally
are taking on an entire persona and this
takes quite a lot of time and practice
to do so not everyone's gonna be able to
do it it kind of depends on what you're
acting and lying and deceit skills are
like so a few principles around pretext
in so you need to do a lot of planning
and research and that's going to lead to
more success so the more forward
planning an effort you put into this the
more successful you're likely to be if
you just go straight in and try and
trick someone the chances are you're
going to fail shared interests make
success more likely so I saying before
if you find the information in their
bins or online about particularly
interest they've gotten you actually
share those interest it's gonna make you
more convincing so if you find out there
and Manchester United fan and you are as
well then you've got a whole wealth of
information you can use just a chat with
them about just to get them to be
confident in you so as I said before
good acting definitely helps if you go
in there and you you know you start
saying lots of hammy
really bad lines or you look really
nervous for fidgety then you're not
gonna come
very convincing also a key thing is
keeping it simple so you don't want to
come up with too much of an elaborate
pretext or persona because the chances
are you're not gonna be able to keep
that going for too long but also as well
you want to use information when you're
talking to these people that doesn't
require any verification so if you asked
if you say something that's maybe
controversial and they then go and fill
they have to look it up or or query what
you says then that can sometimes lead to
you being found out
so pretexting takes a lot of planning so
first of all you need to write down what
it is you aim to achieve and you need to
plan for different reactions that stray
from the happy path as well so you may
have a vision in your mind of going in
and talking to someone and you know
exactly what your goal is and you plot
out that kind of successful path so get
in there but what happens if they say
something you wasn't expecting or you
think you've got some information on the
Boshy it's wrong and they say something
else how are you going to react to that
you're just gonna stand there and like
no and just look confused or if you
actually saw planned out different
scenarios but also when we said about
keeping it simple we're just go in and
being friendly be enough do you need to
go to the effort of putting on a large
Act some people you know you feel just
friendly and nice to them and you just
struck up an instant rapport with them
over time you'll be able to get them to
reveal lots of information so got
another definition of social engineering
here so it's a clever manipulation of
the natural human tendency to trust and
Trust is the kind of the big word there
so you are trying to build up a
relationship with someone with the
intent of them being able to trust you
now this takes a lot of time it's not
instant so you're not gonna walk up to
someone in the pub talk to them for five
minutes and then get what it is you want
out of them the chances are you'll be
talking to them for days weeks or even
months before you actually go in for the
for the killers it was okay so the next
stage is elicitation so elicitation is
the act of getting
information without directly asking for
it so if I go out to you and say what's
your password that's not going to end
very well is it
so elicitation is about getting into
reveal information but you don't
directly have to go in and ask for it
you you gradually coerce it out of them
and generally this is all about
exploiting human nature so most people
want to be polite most people want to be
helpful and people also want to appear
well-informed so if you're targeting
more junior members of staff at an
organization and you're pretending to be
say a higher up manager in this huge
corporation people want to appear well
informed so they want to look come
across as if they don't know what
they're talking about so their way of
appearing to be well informed will be to
tell you lots of information people also
want to be appreciated so you know if
you're going in there and you you're
polite you know you pleat your pleases
and thank-yous that also helps people
trust you and also be more willing to
give out information and generally a
human trait is that people that are
honest don't allow it to withhold
information online so not everyone is a
liar you know people do generally want
to be nice and won't necessarily want
sit withhold information solicitation is
largely about understanding how to
communicate with people and to do this
you need so this comes of experience of
working with people talking with people
and it's also about learning how to
adapt your communications to fit a
situation so as I said before you may
plan for a happy path scenario of how
you try and get some information out of
someone but the chances are something's
going to happen that you're not gonna
have expected so if you're expecting to
have a quiet two-way chat with someone
and it's in a bar but then to their
friend suddenly turn up how you going to
adapt your situation to cater for that
and as well already said you don't want
to just go straight in for the kill to
get the information from people you want
to build up a bond with your target and
this may take a long time it could be
weeks it could be months or maybe even
longer depending on what or who it is
you're trying to get information from
and staying in character of your pre-tax
is very important so imagine you know
your your pre-tax is that you all say a
single person and you're talking to
someone else and then suddenly one day
you forget to take your wedding ring off
before you go and talk to the person you
know that's gonna blow blow your cover
effectively if they notice that you've
got a wedding ring on and also
understand in effective use of
questioning techniques so when we talk
about questioning techniques I've got
four here so we have neutral open closed
and leading questions so a neutral
question is quite a general question it
doesn't really direct the use that user
or the person on how to answer the
question so there's no leading or
directing or coercing so if I say to you
how do you like the weather today that's
kind of quite broad you can answer that
in many different ways
oh I like the fact that it is snowing I
really love the fact that the pavements
are icy and I fell over ten times on the
way to the conference centre you know
you can give a multitude of answers to
it so an open-ended question encourages
a full meaningful answer using the
subjects own knowledge and feelings so
in example here is you know tell me
about the relationship of your father or
how do you feel about the election
candidates again they're still very open
questions there's lots of scope for
people to give you long rambling answers
but on the flip side so that you have
close questions and these help give you
control of a conversation and allow you
to lead where that conversation is going
to go so for example if you say do you
get on with your father you know yes I
do no I don't it's very closed it's not
really that many ways you can answer it
or who you're gonna vote for you know
you're gonna vote for candidate a or
candidate B
then the final one is a leading
questions this is where you're trying to
steer someone down a particular path or
train of thoughts so as an example we
got here do you have any problems with
your boss I've highlighted two words
there Poppins and boss you're kind of
leading them to start thinking about
yeah do I have a problem with my boss
yeah maybe I do I really hate that
finger way slapped me on the back of
that I think nice it's kind of leading
someone in a certain direction well the
other example there was how fast was the
red car going when it smashed into the
blue car its leading you to think that
it was the red car that was going fast
and it smashed into the blue car that
may not have been the case it may have
been the other way around it might be in
the blue car they hit the red car first
so question in you Germany wants to
think of it as like a funnel so you
might start off we've neutralized from
questions you're trying to build a
rapport so you're just having a
conversation with someone you're not
trying to get too specific what you're
talking about then gradually you go down
in sort of more open questions and then
as you start narrowing down to the
target you get more closed so you're
trying to get more definite answer from
them and then there's a last resort you
might go to a more directed question
where you you're very very explicit
about what you're asking for but you're
giving them more scope to answer it so
if it being closed so if you look back
then so pretexting we've talked about is
taking on a persona and elicitation is
using that persona to extract the
information so the pretext is you acting
pretending to be someone else and then
the active elicitation is you then using
that persona to try and draw that
information out of someone so next bit
on that framework was manipulation
so it's wants to define what the to mean
so influencing is influencing someone to
change their minds in a way that is good
for them so if you're out drinking with
your friends and you think your friend
has had two too many drinks and you
suggest that you shouldn't have anymore
you're trying to influence him because
it's good for him manipulation on the
other hand is influencing someone to
make a change or to change their mind in
a way that is not good for them
yeah they don't have enough a bear here
so influencing is about it being a
win-win situation between two people
whereas manipulations win lose so if I'm
trying to manipulate someone's to do
thing that's not in their best interest
it's a win for me but it's a lose for
them no manipulation is generally bad
you know as social creatures we don't
really want to be manipulating people
but for social engineering manipulation
is what it's all about so if we go back
to our original definition from earlier
so it's the act of influencing someone
to take an action that may not be in
their best interest so really what we're
talking about is the act of manipulation
and there's lots and lots and lots of
manipulation technique says huge books
written on the subjects but we're going
to talk about a fuse or common
manipulation techniques so first one is
using fear or the fear and relief
technique so this is a technique where
you offer up a fearful situation to
start with then you immediately offer a
relief to try and build up someone's
trust so as an example here we've got hi
this is tech support we detected a virus
on your machine and it could affect all
of your work files that's the fear so
the person on the phone is probably
thinking oh I'm going to lose all
my work but don't worry we can install
an anti-malware tool you just need to
give us your password so we can remote
log on and install the tool and then the
problem will be gone in a few minutes so
that's the relief so you do immediate
fear offer up relief straight away and
that person would be so shocked at that
point that they're just gonna give you
what you want to get the job done to
make you go away
so using gilts is another manipulation
technique so doing someone a favor
and then using it against them so when
you're doing your information gathering
and going for your planning if you're
pre-taped you might find out that
actually this person's in debt you know
they might owe 5,000 euros on their
credit card and they're struggling to
pay it off because you've seen their
credit card statements and the bin so
you know one thing you could do is you
as you befriend them over time you could
offer to help them with their debt if
you do that then you've got something
code for them because you've helped them
out and you can use that as a guilt
technique later on
you know an example there so I need you
to copy these files for me you owe me a
favor after I kept you know X secret for
you it could be that you found out that
the person you're targeting is having an
affair on their partner and you found
that information out you can also use
that there's a guilt technique because
you know they're not gonna want you to
tell their partner so they'll probably
be more complicit in helping you the
next one is called the foot in the door
technique jeez a lot by salesmen so
asking the victim to do a very small
request first and then once I could pry
follow-on with a real request so one
pretty good one is you know it's not
something you get home there's paper on
the street they'll stop you and they
will ask you the time first and you stop
there you look at your watch oh it's
half past four so you've done a simple
request for you first and immediately
they offer a veneer have you got any
change
it's used by salesmen you know there
will knock on your door they will start
talking to you that ask you how the
wafer is you know they'll ask you
several positive questions and each
response and then once they've done that
they're gonna go in they're going to be
in a position where they're gonna start
trying to sell you something that's
called the foot in the door technique so
that's a very high level sort of look at
the general framework of social
engineering as I say it's on those
subjects you could probably spend your
entire life learning it's all about
psychology and how humans interact but
generally we break it break it down into
those four stages so the information
gathering building up the pretext which
is your persona that you're gonna take
on elicitation is how you gonna draw the
information out of someone using that
persona and you can use manipulation and
influence in techniques to do that so
what can we do about it as individuals
and as companies and actually protecting
yourself from this stuff isn't as hard
as what you might think a lot of it is
good common sense so if we look at some
of the personal mitigation techniques so
common targets might be junior staff
contractors admin staff or support staff
a lot of these people were targeted
because they're going to be probably
more vulnerable in an organization so
junior staff as we said before they're
they're eager to learn eager to help
contractors aren't necessarily going to
have the same vested or emotionally
interest in the companies what a
full-time member of staff might be so
that might be a good type of person to
go for administrative staff you know so
lower-paid jr. had been staff and people
in tech support like her story at the
beginning so a good thing to always do
is if anyone ever enters to build in so
I like the delivery man that was talking
about before he's always asked Troy Dean
and try and verify their ID and also you
want to watch for out of character
questions so if someone starts giving
you some convoluted backstory before
they ask you another question that's
normally a sign that they're trying to
prepare you for another request so if
someone goes in with lots of backstory
then that could be a marker they only
look out for don't let guests roam free
around the building I mean that one
sounds really obvious be surprised how
many companies do it so even the last
company I was at delivery man would turn
up and the receptionist have just Sade
so you know drop the parcel off over
though it all it takes is the delivery
man to walk around the building enter a
server room that could be bad where you
could walk in drop in USB keys on the
floor which have malware installed on
them so never let them roam free don't
plug in USB thumb drives that you leave
lying around it's surprising how many
people still do this especially if you
you know someone drops a 256 gigabyte
thumb drive on the floor I mean they're
reasonably expensive if someone's gonna
sit on the floor they're gonna be quite
happy with their find you know all it
takes a student to plug it in on a
corporate network that hasn't got USB
ports disabled on their machines and
then you can have all sorts of malware
keyloggers screenshot sirs are installed
on the system
being aware of what you were saying so
if you are you know after the company
conference like this or in a bar or in a
restaurant just be conscious of what
you're talking about with who you live
because you never know who's gonna be
sitting around you know if you're you
should never really discuss and think
that's confidential about your
organization or anything that's
commercially sensitive when you're
outside the company because anyone could
be listening they could be deliberately
listening as well because they've
already targeted you so sometimes I
might not even have to use that persona
to elicit information out of you
if you're just being loose lipped in a
bar then you're just gonna give that
information up anyway shredding
documents so this goes for at home and
in the office so bank statements
prescription details anything that's got
your name and address on it financial
documents you should shred them all
before you bin them any utility bills
because those seemingly useless bits of
information to you are actually very
useful to someone else so don't just
throw them in the bin again going back
to the USB thumb drives you shouldn't
really store commercially sensitive
information on thumb drives of these
especially if you've got ones I've got
AES encryption on them that's that's
better but thumb drives are very easy to
lose you can lose your keys very easily
or they can fall out of your pocket use
drive encryption on your laptop or
computers they will come with it by
standard these days a bit lock or on
Windows and you've got the fall vault on
on Apple Mac devices so make sure you
have it configured and running and your
drives being encrypted id----' gain
anything that's very easy to set up but
some people don't do it and if you lose
your machine or it gets stolen you don't
want people to go to read the contents
of the hard drive and again being aware
of who's looking over your shoulder so
if you want to train traveling to work
and you've got your laptop out and
you're just trying to get some work done
in the hour while you're on the train
just be aware of who's looking over your
shoulder or if you're sitting next to a
window and it's dark outside your wood
your screens going to be reflecting off
for that window so if someone's sitting
on a seat behind you to the left they
can probably see what's happening on
your screen despite a reflection on the
way
no.not I've ever looked at anyone's
screen on the train from window and you
have one is educating yourself so
high-level talks like this some of the
books I'm talking about I'll show you at
the end of the course at the end of the
talk and just general courses that you
can get online so educating yourself and
encouraging your company to run similar
training to this is very beneficial
so go on to more sort of corporate
mitigation techniques so these might be
things you have direct to influence of
your company or they might not be you
could at least go and suggest them to
people in your organization so
identifying what information assets are
most valuable and then color coding them
accordingly so if you have documents on
your system or on share points or have
very few story documents you might have
some color codings on the front cover so
common ones are green for okay to
release amber might be release only but
with authorization so you need to get
permission of a line manager before you
email it to anyone and then red would be
confidential do not release but having a
simple color coded system makes it easy
to know at a glance what you can or
can't do with that document so writing a
corporate security policy or a set of
policy documents so these are generally
quite important but I also know through
experience that when companies white
these people don't read them has anyone
ever read their corporate security
policy documents at work on person to
Germany people don't read them because
they're a bit long and boring but they
are important to have in place because
it gives the company guidance and
leverage on what they can do if any of
those policies are broken if you haven't
got one in your company or it's a fairly
small company you can go to this website
here at Sans dot org and they have a
load of template documents that you can
use so it might not be completely
relevant for everything that your
company does but it's a good starting
point if you do put these documents in
place as I said people aren't
necessarily gonna read them so you want
to get your companies to put training in
place as well so you actually have an
instructor-led session where a fairly
high level or medium level someone in
the company will go
three what's in those documents and then
you get someone to sign off that they've
taken that course at the end because
then the company should be able to use
those documents as a way of noting
punishes and rightward but there needs
to be some kind of comeback so if
someone does break some of the policy
documents they need to be held to how to
account for it this one's a big one
which doesn't always happen but should
he's keeping software updated and
patched so as well as using a social
engineering techniques people are going
to be trying to install malware and
taking taken advantage of different
vulnerabilities in different software so
keeping your systems passion up-to-date
is very important and this one follows
on from what was talking about shredding
but if you're in a larger organization
you should maybe set up a document
shredding service where you have from
those fair party companies install you
know the big document bins in your
company and then they turn up with a van
and they all shred them on-site in bulk
very useful to have pretty much all the
large companies I've worked have all had
confidential waste disposal systems or
document disposal systems for getting
rid of anything important especially
when I worked in healthcare there's
quite a lot of sensitive information
that we had access to which was printed
out never assume your company is too
small to be a target another thing that
people do is they think you know oh you
know my 15 person company who's going to
target us they're gonna be going after
the big banks or the big companies not
necessarily a smaller company might be
easier for them to get information on
and you know someone could be working on
behalf of a larger competitor who's
trying to find out what it is exactly
that your company is doing so they might
try and get information about the
products you build in and then they'll
sell it back to a larger competitor okay
so let's go for a quick summary of what
we've gone through here
so social engineering is the acts of
influencing someone to take on an action
that may not be in their best interest
you can get lots of different types of
people doing social engineering so
penetration testers are kind of the
genuine ethical type who will do this
against companies to test their systems
and staff but you can have lots of
people that do this for bad and farías
reasons including children or mine
anyway people do social engineering
because it consistently works and the
people in an organization are the
biggest threat to any network so it
doesn't matter how much you spent on
hardware and software to protect your
systems all it takes is one person not
doing what they're supposed to be doing
or giving out information and then your
systems compromised and also it's
generally a path of least resistance so
if someone's trying to get passwords you
know they could go you know try and do
an internal hack and try and get the
password file from your database the
password tables and brute force it or
they could just try and coerce someone
into revealing their password so the
techniques we looked at it was a four
stage process so information gathering
is all about gathering information about
the company and the people that you're
trying to target so you can use anything
from going through people's rubbish
through to looking on social networks
and googling them you'd be surprised how
much information you can get mean has
anyone ever googled themselves to find
out what they could find yeah did you
find quite a lot of information that you
wasn't expecting no okay
so pretexting is the next stage and this
is all about taking on a persona it's
all about acting you're trying to take
on a persona to fool someone into
thinking that you're someone else and
then using that persona you'll use
elicitation and different questioning
techniques to try and draw that
information out of someone so you're not
going to go in and directly ask them
what their past where it is or what the
product is they're working or make them
suspicious but over time if you build up
a rapport with them so you go out
drinking with them you might even
socialize by praying for taking up
sports with them then
you just do that for several months
before you even think of asking about
any information it builds up rapport and
it builds up trust and off the back of
that we looks at some manipulation
techniques and looked at the differences
between influencing which is win-win
scenario and manipulation which is a
win-lose scenario so one person benefits
while the other person loses and then
finally we looked at some personal and
corporate mitigation techniques so the
thing you probably would have drawn from
that it's all those techniques actually
very simple they're straightforward
fairly common sense but it's surprising
how many people when companies don't do
some of those things are being aware of
what you're saying when you're out and
about so conferences or in bars but I'm
taxes yeah that that'd be a good one for
that earlier slide actually taxi drivers
because they're very talkative and we we
got an uber last night going back to the
hotel and he was probably the chattiest
taxi driver I've spoken to in a while
yeah absolutely
so just idle chitchat in the back of the
taxi definitely okay so a few resources
that you can use which are quite good
I've got a course on Pluralsight which I
did with a good friend Lars Clint he's a
kind of covers a lot the information
that we've talked about today if you
ever wanted to go back and refresh
yourself the books by kevin Mitnick I
highly recommend reading them having
every security professional or anyone
interested in software development
should read his books they are
absolutely fascinating this book here
called social engineering the art of
human hacking is a massive bacchus
probably a good thousand or so pages but
it's kind of one of the definitive text
books in his field now every field has
its definitive textbook and for social
engineering this this is it
so if you wanted to go into a lot more
detail your follows a rough guide of
what we talked today but it goes into
loads more detail loads more techniques
and one thing we didn't have tons to
cover on today is about body language
because body language is a very good
technique for trying to do a pre-tax
and being able to read body language
seeing how people are reacting to your
questions
this guy here called Joe Navarro he's an
ex FBI field agent he was an expert in
reading body language when it came to
interrogating people so this book talks
about lots of different techniques so if
someone's sitting a desk and you're
talking to them they're stapling their
hands that's normally a sign of
confidence now if you're rubbing your
legs that miss a sign that you're
nervous if your legs and feet are
pointing towards the door it means
you're uncomfortable
it means you want to make a quick escape
those are just sort of free examples and
he goes through a whole range of
different techniques he also talks about
how just by reading someone's body
language from watching videos back they
manage to convict a murderer that they
was dropped into convicts so that's it
thank you very much it's the end of the
conference I hope everyone's had a good
NDC security so my name's Steven haunts
I do lots of training and generally
around cryptography and agile software
developments and also an offer for
Pluralsight so I've done 12 courses for
pool site now and you if you go to many
conferences you'll frequently see me on
the on the speaking gigs up in to NDC
Oslo a few times NDC London Sydney Tech
our armored sdd lots of events like that
so you can of cual off and find me
hanging out at these conferences and I
also run a user group in the UK so if
anyone's ever near Nottingham or Derby
in the UK on the last Thursday of every
month they feel free to come to my he's
a group it's a dotnet software
development group it's a good fun and
it's free so thank you very much thanks
for coming
[Applause]